bon mesdames Messieurs chers collègues
après la réunion que nous avons fait
avec la réunion ce matin nous
poursuivons notre auditions sur le
foncier agricole dans les outre-mer en
nous transportant cet après-midi par
visio conférence en Guadeloupe j'ai de
nouveau l'honneur de remplacer le
président Stéphane Artano qui vous prie
de l'excuser car il est actuellement en
route pour Saint-Pierre et Miquelon nous
tenons donc une table ronde sur la
situation du foncier agricole en
Guadeloupe qui réunit pour le conseil
départemental de la Guadeloupe monsieur
Blaise mornal troisième Brice président
et président de la commission
agriculture développement rural et
affaires foncière
pour la direction de l'alimentation de
l'agriculture et de la forêt monsieur
Sylvain Vedel le directeur pour
l'établissement public foncier de
Guadeloupe Monsieur Patrick célin
président accompagné de Madame Corinne
vengatarama directrice pour la Chambre
d'Agriculture de Guadeloupe Monsieur
Patrick sévère qui est un également le
président accompagné de Monsieur Francis
Thomson directeur et Stéphane soudain
chef du pôle foncier et territoire pour
la SAFER monsieur Rodrigue trèfle
président accompagné de Monsieur Tony
l'enclume conseiller foncier pour l' ONF
madame Mylène Musquet directrice
régionale de la Guadeloupe pour
l'association Cap Guadeloupe Madame
Nathalie minatchi présidente et pour le
syndicat des jeunes agriculteurs
monsieur Maurice Damas administrateur
mesdames messieurs merci pour votre
disponibilité dans un premier temps vous
allez avoir la parole pour une dizaine
de minutes sur la base d'une trame de
questions qui vous a été adressée ce
propos luminaire est bien sûr à ajuster
en fonction des missions qui vous
concernent en tant que rapporteur mon
collègue tany Mohamed Souali en
visioconférence enfin je crois qui est
bien ne s'excuser mais il est dans un
endroit où ça ne capte pas donc il ne
pourra pas être ma compagnie aujourd'hui
et moi-même puisque nous sommes tous les
deux les rapporteurs sur ce texte
pourront à tout moment solliciter de
votre part des précisions
complémentaires ensuite je donnerai la
parole à ceux de mes collègues qu'il a
demandéont alors on m'a fait part d'une
contrainte horaire concernant monsieur
Boris Damas du jeune du syndicat des
jeunes agriculteurs donc si vous en êtes
d'accord je vais d'abord laisser la
parole à Monsieur Blaise mornal du
conseil départemental de la de loupe
présentez ces observations pour lancer
la table ronde puis je la donnerai à
Monsieur Damas qui pourra intervenir et
ensuite on reprendra dans l'ordre que
j'ai énoncé tout à l'heure je vous
remercie et je donne sans plus attendre
la parole à Monsieur Blaise mornal
oui bonjour à tous bonjour
à certains collègues
je vois à l'écran et c'est un
collaborateur ici et certaines personnes
avec qui nous travaillons en état de
collaboration
tout d'abord je voudrais dire que
concernant le l'agriculture le Conseil
départemental
le Conseil départemental à la gestion de
du foncier dont
il est propriétaire
que c'est un fossible le Conseil
départemental mais en bail sur
tout ce qui concerne l'agriculture et le
Conseil départemental aussi à une
compétences sur tout ce qui concerne
l'obligation
concernant le foncier agricole il faut
savoir que ce foncier du conseil
départemental et gérer par la commission
agricole dans un premier temps qui donne
un avis sur les différents projets et
sur le renouvellement des bouts existant
éventuellement et sur la transmission
aussi de ces bola sachant qu'il y a une
réglementation bien définie sur
la transmission et son installation des
agriculteurs sur le fonciers du
département
je précise que
depuis 2014 les élus ont décidé que le
sur le foncier du conseil départemental
sera installé que les les agriculteurs
qui sont qui ont une formation en
agriculture
et qui en font de leur métier
pourquoi parce que dans le passé on
s'est rendu compte que on avait dû
désinstaller sur l'offier du département
et cela de manière très aléatoire et
donc nous avons décidé de mettre de
l'ordre sur ses attributions du conseil
départemental sur le foncier du conseil
départemental c'est une opération qui
prend du temps parce que c'est avec le
temps que les choses se mettent en place
parce que lorsqu'il y a quelqu'un qui a
un bail sur sur le vent il faut il faut
que ça arrive à terme pour pouvoir
vérifier les conditions
d'installation de cette personne là et
éventuellement si les conditions ne
répondent plus le bail n'est pas
reconduit
donc
concernant tout ce qui est
je dirais
le système d'irrigation donc il faut
savoir que il y a un partenariat qui est
mis en place
avec la Région Guadeloupe et le Conseil
départemental et je peux prendre pour
exemple le barrage de Moreau qui vient
d'être réalisé par le Conseil régional
pour une mise à disposition de notre cul
de 2 millions de mètres cubes d'eau pour
l'élégation mais c'est la le département
qui gère la gestion de cette structure
et donc aujourd'hui
nous
nous élements un petit peu l'ensemble du
territoire et bien sûr il y a des
difficultés que nous rencontrons par
rapport à cette obligation parce que
comme partout dans le monde nous
traversons des périodes de sécheresse et
en période sécheresse la distribution de
l'eau sur
potentiel et essayer d'autres nous avons
l'obligation nous nous pouvons nous
obligation de faire des tours en
parallèle on connaît tous les
difficultés que l'on rencontre sur
la Guadeloupe
au niveau de l'eau potable et à notre
niveau on est dans l'obligation aussi
par rapport à cette situation
délicate de la distribution de l'eau
potable de combiner aussi au-delà de la
disposition de l'eau aux agriculteurs de
signer aussi des conventions avec
je dirais les établissements qui qui
gèrent les l'eau potable au pouvoir
fournir de l'eau agricole qui est par la
suite
traités et
traiter afin d'être
distribué sur le réseau de l'eau potable
donc
dire que c'est une situation
facile en Guadeloupe de gérer tout ça
je dirais qu'on véritablement des
difficultés on est sur une île dans un
premier temps
des surfaces de ne sont pas extensibles
par contre nous avons des pistes
d'amélioration de la situation que nous
avons retenu aujourd'hui
nous sommes très de travailler sur
l'installation et le fonctionnement de
la de la
sédaf
afin d'identifier
le terme qui sont en friche qui sont
insuffisamment cultivés pour pouvoir
soit remettre la culture ce fossile là
soit
ou ce qui sont en friche pour mettre en
culture et pour ceux qui sont
suffisamment cultivés
un moyen les moyens pour pouvoir
accompagner les agriculteurs afin
qu'il puisse optimiser en tout cas le
l'exploitation de les débarcelles qui
sont suffisamment cultiver
en parallèle nous travaillons nos trois
collaboration
avec le la Chambre d'Agriculture la
SAFER
au pouvoir améliorer et la Région
Guadeloupe aussi parce qu'il se trouve
que nous avons du foncier les divisions
avec la Région Guadeloupe et donc en
parallèle nous travaillons pour
optimiser aussi l'occupation de ce
foncier là et pour aussi
identifier tout ce foncier qui
éventuellement serait en fiche sur la
somme du territoire de la guadel des
fois ce smooth c'est du foncier qui
appartient au conseil départemental qui
appartient à la région mais qui
appartient aussi au service de l'État
la difficulté c'est aujourd'hui c'est
une compétence qui qui est porté par le
Conseil départemental pour pouvoir
mettre en place et faire fonctionner
cette cette date mais malheureusement
le financement et au niveau le
financement qui pourrait être disponible
pour faire fonctionner cela et au niveau
de la région et à travers le fait à
l'air et donc ça prélève difficulté
de fonctionnement et de d'efficacité en
tout cas parce qu'il faut véritablement
trouver un bon consensus ou pour cela
puisse véritablement prendre son envol
donc pour vous donner quelques
précisions
sur l'irrigation
aujourd'hui c'est un budget annuel de 2
à 7 millions d'euros en moyenne qui sont
qui est consacré
à l'obligation c'est aujourd'hui c'est
600 km de réseau il y a 6 prises d'eau
pompage au niveau du territoire
et ça représente environ
8000 hectares de terre irrigués pour
3100 abonnés sur sur le territoire
donc à travers les différentes
discussions que nous avons avec les
différentes institutions
aussi un accompagnement financier pour
permettre aux différents filières de
pouvoir se développer de pouvoir être
opérationnel sur le territoire de la
Guadeloupe je vais finir en disant que
la demande elle est de plus en plus
importante sur
l'irrigation
au niveau du territoire parce que nous
avons constaté
qu'il y a une autre forme d'agriculture
qui se développe et qui demande beaucoup
plus de moyens non et particulièrement
tout ce qui concerne les exploitations
des melonniers qui aujourd'hui se
trouvait particulièrement au niveau du
sud de la zone terre et depuis quelques
temps il y a de grandes exploitations
qui se développent dans le nord-inter
ils se sont des
exploitations qui se trouvent en bout de
réseau et donc ça fait le besoin nous
est plus importantes et donc nous
pouvons nous devons réfléchir pour
trouver des pistes pour pouvoir répondre
à la demande et c'est pour ça que une
étude est menée actuellement sur le sud
de la bastère ou éventuellement
construire un nouveau barrage qui
pourrait
être dans une dimension de 5 millions de
mètres cubes d'eau pour pouvoir les
servir le secteur et apporter une aide
amélioration en tout cas
au réseau en nous et à l'éducation sur
le territoire malheureusement
le dossier environnemental a fait
l'objet négatif du Conseil national de
la protection de la nature
une étude de en cours de reprise pour
pouvoir nous apporter éventuellement des
éléments qui pourraient améliorer pour
répondre et obtenir un habit favorable
je dirais du Conseil national
donc j'aurais éventuellement à revenir
sur des points qui nécessiteraient des
éclaircissements concernant je dirais la
compétence que nous portons du conseil
départemental déjà sur la gestion du
Fossier qui nous appartient et mais
aussi sur la gestion de l'éducation et
éventuellement apporter aussi des
réponses sur la vision que nous avons
sur le développement
de la culture de sa globalité sur le
territoire de la Guadeloupe
très bien merci Monsieur le
vice-président alors je crois que
Monsieur Boris Damas est pris par
temps à cause de l'horaire où il doit
être doit se rendre donc je vais lui
donner tout de suite la parole pour
qu'il puisse s'exprimer monsieur Damas
c'est à vous
oui donc bonjour à tous Boris Damas
administrateur jeune agriculteur
donc si vous voulez l'idée aujourd'hui
c'est que on a eu des remontées au
niveau de notre syndicat des adhérents
de notre syndicat et c'est de pouvoir
vous présenter un peu les grandes
problématiques et les solutions les
pistes de solution qu'on a on a pu
évoquer lors des réunions et donc il
faut comprendre qu'aujourd'hui pour nous
lorsqu'on fait une observation de la
façon dont les choses sont organisées de
la façon dont le foncier est organisé
sur un territoire insulaire c'est vrai
qu'il est un peu compliqué de pouvoir
prendre des décisions pour le
développement agricole aujourd'hui on
subit par exemple des pressions je
dirais économique on a besoin de plus en
plus d'infrastructures économiques de
route de plus en plus large qui mange du
foncier une urbanisation économique
ensuite on a une pression
démographique qui fait que derrière
chacun veut sa villa et donc forcément
ça mobilise de plus en plus de fonciers
et derrière on a également une pression
environnementale qui fait que on a
besoin de plus en plus d'espace de
biodiversité d'espace protégés et donc
c'est aussi des des surfaces qui sont
rognées de plus en plus sur le le
foncier agricole à titre d'exemple c'est
on a vu que lors des des validations de
plu c'est du lorsqu'on pouvait
rencontrer des parcelles agricoles qui
n'étaient pas cultivées justement
parlait de terrain chez tout si jamais
effectivement une végétation spontanée
place parfois ces espaces étaient
sanctualisés et de type N et donc
forcément derrière la le développement
agricole devenait devient de plus en
plus compliqué donc ça ce sont des
éléments à garder en tête lorsqu'on on
pose une analyse sur sur le foncier
agricole et je pense que c'est quelque
chose
d'assez important à dire après nous on a
décidé effectivement de vous présenter
les choses de très simple en prenant en
compte la ligne de conduite que vous
nous avez demandé et présenter autre au
niveau des différentes questions donc
effectivement on observe que sur les 20
dernières années qu'il y a une
diminution de plus de 10000 hectares
de foncer agricole et c'est vrai que sur
les 20 ans lors des dernières réunions
on a pu constater que c'était peut-être
les 10 premières années mais que c'est
sous les 10 dernières années cette
urbanisation du foncier a beaucoup
diminué on parle même que sous les 5
dernières années qui a pas eu de perte
de France à l'école donc ça c'est une
bonne chose maintenant effectivement il
faut qu'on puisse s'assurer que ce
foncier est préservé mais surtout
derrière est-ce qu'on peut pas avoir
porté des réflexions sur de la
conversion de fonciers vers du foncier
agricole donc ça c'est l'interrogation
qu'on a et tout à l'heure je vais vous
présenter éventuellement les pistes de
solutions qu'on pourrait avoir
donc forcément il faut qu'il y ait un
renforcement destructures de gestion
foncière ça peut être la safeur ou autre
mais priorités là ça ferme après sur la
deuxième question vous nous parlez de
taxation
de foncier alors
nous aujourd'hui lorsqu'on a porté cette
réflexion c'est vrai que
l'analyse qu'on fait c'est
parfois les
propriétés offensiers ont tendance à
chercher des pistes pour pouvoir
déclasser ou effectivement ne pas mettre
en culture des parcelles et c'est vrai
que parfois c'est que la répression qui
peut marcher donc l'analyse qu'on a fait
c'est est-ce que il faut il fallait
enclencher sur une question liée à la
taxation ou inciter financièrement à la
remise en culture lorsqu'on a consulté
de l'expérience que certains autres
départements avaient sur les questions
liées à la à l'incitation à la culture
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y a pas mal
de gros entrepreneurs qui prenaient le
pas et c'est vrai que ça ça c'était au
désavantage de
d'agriculture je dirais
à échelle humaine
et donc la réflexion qui a été portée au
niveau de de notre de notre syndicat
c'est effectivement une taxation qui
devait être mise en place pour favoriser
la remise en culture
des parcelles quand en fait si jamais le
propriétaire se retrouve dans une
situation
où il n'a pas le choix parce que parce
qu'effectivement
les taxes sont assez lourdes mais
derrière on peut espérer que les
parcelles soient remise en culture
ensuite la question liée par rapport au
droit de préemption de la Safia
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est très intéressant très
intéressant cette question liée à la à
la préhension des affaires le problème
qui se pose c'est que sur les doigts de
préemption qu'est-ce qui se passe
souvent c'est
les propriétaires
à partir du moment où ils ont pas les
montants qu'ils veulent mais ils
prennent la décision de retirer le bien
à la vente et ça aujourd'hui nous ça
nous pose un problème parce qu'on
retourne effectivement à la situation où
la pensée n'est pas mise en vente ou
effectivement
elle est pas valorisée et derrière c'est
négatif pour l'agriculture européenne
donc ce qu'on propose effectivement le
lien entre la question précédente et
cette question il faut que les affaires
soient renforcés et est ce droit à
l'appréhension mais derrière lorsque le
propriétaire prend la décision de
retirer le le bien à la vente la
parcelle est identifiée à partir du
moment où elle est identifiée il faut
qu'on puisse appliquer une surtaxation
sur cette parcelle pour obliger le le
propriétaire à remettre la pensée en
culture en vente parce que ça peut pas
être une histoire de en voiture une
parcelle en vente en espérant un jour
qu'elle passe en déclassement et que
derrière on puisse se dire ah ben quand
il sera déclassé je vais là je vais
lancer la partie en vente c'est une
pensée qui est identifié comme étant une
parcelle agricole si le propriétaire
fait le choix de la vente il faut
qu'elle la vendre à un tarif agricole
donc on pense que effectivement il
faudrait renforcer en ce sens
ensuite quel bilan qu'on peut
effectivement dresser de la loi
l'alchimie la loi l'alchimie c'est une
très bonne loi ok c'est une loi pour
nous qui
qui fonctionne maintenant effectivement
je pense aux jeunes agriculteurs qu'il
faut renforcer
encore la loi est-ce qu'il se passe
effectivement là la problématique c'est
que on a plusieurs décennies
de problèmes de succession et
d'indivisions foncière sur le territoire
de la Guadeloupe
et donc la première la première
problématique c'est quel est notre
capacité à identifier les propriétaires
on peut imaginer qu'on est sur deux ou
trois générations ou la documentation ou
les successions n'ont pas été faites et
donc lorsqu'on arrive à une troisième
génération où on est on se retrouve avec
des cousins de cousins qui sont sur une
même parcelle de 4 hectares on peut
imaginer que ça devienne assez que de
pouvoir identifier tout le monde et
de pouvoir effectivement
faire les actions nécessaires
pour garantir effectivement la remise en
culture de de ses parcelles donc on
pense qu'il faut effectivement
renforcer cette loi pour que derrière on
puisse
avoir une forme d'efficacité de remise
en culture sur les parcelles
qu'est-ce que nous on propose
qu'est-ce que nous on propose par
rapport à ça alors je vais peut-être un
trou de mémoire tout ça donc
je me souviens pas donc on va pas se
faire autre chose et puis je reviendrai
là-dessus comme ça ça me reviendra
alors concernant les questions liées à
la cdp9 aujourd'hui effectivement depuis
que la vie conforme de la CVD P9 a été
mise en place
globalement je pense que autour a priori
autour de 80% le le les choses se sont
faites de manière correcte et on peut
nous favoriser effectivement le maintien
de la vie conforme sur le territoire de
la Guadeloupe
par contre effectivement on se retrouve
face à je dirais un changement de modèle
agricole en Guadeloupe et on a de plus
en plus de jeunes qui s'orientent vers
une diversification
qu'est-ce que cela veut dire ça veut
dire que derrière on a de plus en plus
besoin d'avoir
un lieu d'habitation directement sur
l'exploitation par contre on discute
avec des pincettes il s'agit pas de se
dire que
on arrive et puis qu'on construit sa
villa piscine sur l'exploitation c'est
pas ce qu'on dit ce qu'on dit ce qu'il
faut qu'on ait un point satellite sur
l'exploitation pour que lorsqu'on fait
de l'élevage lorsqu'on fait des cultures
sensibles lorsque on a besoin d'une
présence permanente sur l'exploitation
on est la possibilité de la faire je
tiens à rappeler que la qualité d'un
produit
dépend de notre capacité à réagir
rapidement lorsqu'on trouve un problème
prenez la qualité d'un produit quel est
notre capacité à être présent dans ce
qu'on rencontre un problème et de
pouvoir réagir alors que lorsqu'on
habite effectivement à 3,4 km à 10 km à
15 km de l'exploitation ben c'est c'est
autant de perte qu'on peut rencontrer
sur sur les productions donc il s'agit
effectivement de définir sur ces zones
sensibles sur ces zones protégées de
production agricole un schéma
[Musique]
ok donc c'est pas on fait pas n'importe
quoi c'est une un type effectivement de
maison qui serait mise en place pour
pouvoir derrière avoir une présence et
cette maison serait affiliée directement
à l'exportation donc au capital de
l'exploitation et au moment où
l'agriculture part à la retraite comme
ça se fait dans dans les régions en
hexagone il faudrait que
l'habitation puisse être vendue en même
temps que le capital exploitation donc
c'est pas il repart avec la maison pour
lui pour finir sa retraite c'est la
maison l'habitation est liée à
l'exploitation et au capital de
l'exploitation et donc derrière
lorsqu'il part en retraite ben c'est une
habitation qui reste sur l'exploitation
qui reste au capital d'exploitation et
qui est à disposition du repreneur pour
la continuité des des cultures mais
indéniablement aujourd'hui on rentre sur
une diversification agricole et donc
derrière ça veut dire quoi il faut une
présence sur l'exploitation et ça c'est
une chose qu'on a ciblé
alors concernant effectivement le
recensement agricole ça c'est je pense
le cœur de métier de jeune agriculteur
c'est le renouvellement de génération on
arrive à une période effectivement
sensible où il faut enclencher sur
renouvellement de génération il faut
mettre les choses en place pour que
derrière on puisse
enclencher cette nouvelle génération qui
arrive qu'en plus installer massivement
des agriculteurs afin de garantir les
effectivement les fondamentaux qui sont
la souveraineté alimentaire
la grande problématique c'est quelle est
notre capacité à faire des agriculteurs
partir en retraite et derrière quelle
est notre capacité à installer
massivement des jeunes sur ses parcelles
on rencontre que on se rend compte que
sous la territoire guadeloupéen on a du
mal à faire partie des agriculteurs on
va être faites pourquoi parce que il y a
des problématiques autour de la retraite
donc au vu des questions que vous nous
avez posées nous on a on a on valide la
question de la SPA par contre faut pas
oublier qu'on est sur un territoire
insulaire que la vie est plus importante
ici que le pouvoir d'achat est diminué
donc on aimerait que
il y a un tour un peu plus élevé pour
favoriser le départ à la retraite
aujourd'hui on parle de 961 minimum euro
en retraite ce serait l'idée ce serait
de pouvoir ajouter peut-être 20 % à ce à
ce montant en parallèle de ce que les
fonctionnaires touchent déjà des 40 %.
on dit pas qu'il faut mettre 40 %. mais
si on met 20 % on serait déjà un montant
autour de 1100 euros de retraite qui
serait disponible pour que les avis
culture puisse effectivement libérer le
foncier et derrière qu'on puisse
favoriser les installations qu'est-ce
qui se passe on se retrouve avec des
agriculteurs qui sont pour beaucoup
fatigués qui ne cultivent pas une grande
de l'eau foncier et derrière c'est
autant de pensées qui sont pas mis en
culture parce qu'on ne peut pas
installer de jeu
passer ce
cette question liée à la retraite il
faut effectivement activer certaines
dispositifs qui existent selon moi
un hexagone notamment les les
dispositifs Aita pizzilia qui ont pu
exister enfin tous ces dispositifs qui
permettent d'enclencher une fluidité
dans la question liée à la transmission
je pense qu'il faudrait qu'on travaille
là-dessus pour pouvoir les activer sur
le territoire de la Guadeloupe
après celle liée au manque d'eau le
collègue juste avant effectivement bien
présenté les choses mais ce qu'il faut
je pense retenir et qui est un élément
important c'est que des investissements
ont été faits pour le secteur agricole
pour de l'eau agricole sur le territoire
de la Guadeloupe et que aujourd'hui
c'est structures sont oh orientés
vers de la production d'eau potable
parce qu'on se retrouve face à une
problématique de production d'eau
potable sur les territoires le problème
qui se pose c'est que on est un peu dans
un système où le serpent se mord la
queue c'est autant d'eau qui sont pas
envoyés sur le la production agricole
donc je pense qu'il faut encore
continuer à travailler
précédemment les jeunes s'orientent
beaucoup vers une diversification des
productions donc forcément besoin en eau
on est plus sur des modèles
traditionnels de production de
canne notamment dans je prends le
secteur du Nord Basse-Terre
on a beaucoup de jeunes qui sont engagés
sous des systèmes labels type
agriculture biologiques ou autre
qui veulent s'engager sur des
la diversification alimentaire la
diversification en production mais
derrière ils ont besoin de struction en
eau aujourd'hui c'est une zone alors
qu'on est le deuxième gros bassin de la
Guadeloupe qui n'est pas alimenté en
noir agricole
je pense qu'il y a des travaux à lancer
pour pouvoir alimenter cette zone en
agricoles et que derrière en plus
effectivement garantir cette production
pour le territoire de la Guadeloupe
alors concernant les les établissements
de type EPF
ça fait et autres
aujourd'hui il faudrait effectivement
que
payer une concertation que c'est
différentes organisations arrivent à
travailler ensemble parce que selon nous
on pourrait réaliser effectivement de
grandes choses
l'objectif de l'EPF
selon nous c'est un on voit que
aujourd'hui des grands travaux sont
lancés de grandes réflexions sont
lancées sur les hommes
urbanisés
qui continuent effectivement en ce sens
pour éviter que l'urbanisation Vienne
rogner le fonds agricole donc tout ce
qui est abandon de structure abandon de
bâtiments il faut réhabiliter
l'expérience de l'EPF nous montre que
ils ont je dirais une force qui
[Musique]
est dans la
je veux pas utiliser de motifs mais
je dirais je sais pas si c'est selon moi
mais bon je dis comme ça me vient lié à
l'expropriation c'est-à-dire que
lorsqu'on répond pas effectivement aux
lois qu'on respecte pas les lois ils ont
cette capacité à pouvoir capter un bien
et à le remettre en circulation je pense
que c'est une force parce que lorsque le
bien est en abandon que c'est une ruine
je pense notamment à tout ce qui se fait
sur Pointe-à-Pitre et tout et qu'ils ont
cette capacité qu'ils ont cette
expérience pour pouvoir récupérer le
bien et le remettre à disposition il
faudrait qu'on puisse utiliser cette
force aussi dans le secteur agricole
et donc je pense qu'ils ont des budgets
qui sont
lorsqu'on a regardé un peu les textes
qui sont intéressants
et il faudrait peut-être s'inspirer de
ça pour que derrière on puisse faire
effectivement la même chose sur le
secteur agricole donc les maîtres
peut-être au même piédestal PF travail
en collaboration que le PF là ça fait et
autres autres structures
maintenant si tout cette même question
liée à
offenser agricole
vous savez on va on va on va présenter
énormément de choses je vais pas
m'attarder longtemps on va présenter
énormément de choses mais nous lorsqu'on
observe on se retrouve à être une
génération de jeunes agriculteurs qui
veulent s'installer
ou le sentiment qu'on a c'est qu'il ne
reste que les miettes de foncière en
Guadeloupe c'est à dire que toutes les
belles parcelles tous les plateaux tout
ça sont des gens culture et nous on se
retrouve avec je dirais les miettes pour
preuve on a quelques agriculteurs
aujourd'hui qui sont installés sous des
parcelles ou
je sais pas comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait dire aux enfants mais dans le
Nord c'est de la caille il y a très peu
de de fonciers réel sous ses parcelles
qui sont cultivables et donc nous ça
nous pose un problème
je tiens à rappeler que le département
est le grand propriétaire foncier de la
Guadeloupe effectivement il y a des
pensées agricoles et à des parcelles qui
sont sur d'autres statuts
le pèse mes mots
on a du foncier sanctuarisé
parc national Claude OK et il y a des
parcelles du foncier qui était destiné
je dirais à la culture de bois
ok donc faut rester
aujourd'hui sont sanctuaires
en espace forest
comme si il s'agissait de
[Rires]
on vous entend plus monsieur
on ne vous entend plus
donc aujourd'hui nous on est une vague
de jeunes qui veulent s'installer
ça coupe
on nous entend plus
allô vous avez disparu de nos écrans
et se reconnecter
un nouveau oui
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez entendu le début
que de ce que j'ai dit par rapport
aux hommes forestiers non
ok
on commence à travailler sur des
réflexions qu'on va porter par rapport
au Conseil on se retrouve face à des
situations où
et là je répète je pense que ce sont des
mots qui m'ont été rapportés au niveau
de du syndicat face à des
du foncier
[Musique]
sanctuarisé comme des espaces forestiers
endémique de foyadémique alors que ce
sont des plantations à vocation
d'exploitation forestière qui était à
l'origine
donc on a une vague de jeune aujourd'hui
qui arrive et qui veulent s'installer
sur des dispositifs de production
agro-écologique
c'est parcelles qui sont je dirais sur
caution ONF
qui sont normalement à vocation à
culture d'exploitation forestière sont
aujourd'hui sanctuarisés comme si ce
sont des forêts endémiques de la
Guadeloupe le parc national
est une forêt endémique le cœur de
Pâques doit être protégé on est d'accord
par contre effectivement l'ONF
aujourd'hui avec le département ont plus
de 38000 hectares de de
foncier il serait intéressant de
commencer à porter une réflexion sur des
parcelles qui devraient être mises en
culture
agroécologique je dirais donc d'un
système de production
agroforestia je parle pas de ce que
aujourd'hui ce qui existe aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas de la culture ce n'est pas de
la production agricole ça c'est de
je dirais de
l'extrémisme écologique
on peut pas me dire qu'aujourd'hui sur
le territoire de la Guadeloupe alors que
normalement 10
000 arbres à lector
donc je pense que ce sont des certaines
parcelles de ce de certains de ses
fonciers devraient être mis en culture
je répète sous des systèmes
agroécologiques où on pourrait parler
d'élevage sous bois de culture sous bois
avec des densités de 200 arbres hectares
et ça pourrait créer du lien
effectivement entre la production de
bois et les cultures
agricoles parce que on est fatigué de se
retrouver dans des situations où on
installe des jeunes dans des zones de
conflits je prends l'exemple encore de
goyave où on fait comme projeter des
jeunes dans des situations ou après leur
culture sont complètement détruites où
on pousse des jeunes et là je prends
bien évidemment des pincettes avec la
sédence on va propulser des jeunes dans
des zones aujourd'hui où les personnes
qui sont présentes dans ces zones là ça
menacent de sortir les angles
il faut qu'on fasse très attention alors
oui on doit être dans des zones de
négociation mais les négociations vont
prendre combien de temps là on est dans
un renouvellement de génération où il
faut installer plus de 2000 agriculteurs
rapidement donc il faut qu'on puisse
trouver des solutions rapides bien
évidemment en parallèle c'est
négociations continuent de d'avancer
mais derrière on a déclenché du foncé
réellement
pour pouvoir installer massivement une
vague de jeune et que derrière on
reprenne les produits la production en
Guadeloupe
je pense que c'était quelque chose à
dire et pour finir la question liée
aux filières maraîchère est-ce qu'elle
doit être sur des modèles camp de
bananes
la banane est un bon exemple parce que
il me semble qu'avant il y avait
plusieurs coopératives aujourd'hui si
elle fonctionne c'est parce qu'il y a
une seule coopérative
et elle fonctionne
donc faut s'inspirer de ça c'est la
question que je vous retourne parce que
visiblement quand il y a plusieurs
coopératives et que tout le monde
produit de la tomate en même temps ben
ça devient problématique sur le
territoire de la Guadeloupe et
aujourd'hui la réalité c'est que les
jeunes de la Guadeloupe sont à 100% pour
l'organisation des filiales
sauf que lorsqu'on a des jeunes qui sont
engagés dans ces coopératives et qu'ils
ont des créances de plus de 20000 euros
je vous cache pas que le lendemain ils
prennent leur marchandises et ils vont
sur le marché de Gaulle pour avoir du
cash tout de suite
donc je pense que je garderai ça pour le
mot de la fin et je vous remercie
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur je
passe tout de suite la parole à Monsieur
Sylvain Vedel directeur de la DAF
oui bonjour mesdames et messieurs vous
m'entendez
oui très bien
ok je vais essayer de faire rapide et de
me concentrer sur les sujets qui sont
plus en lien avec l'activité de la DAF
d'abord sur la situation globale du
foncier agricole je voudrais revenir sur
le premier point que vous évoquez avec
la baisse constatée de foncier agricole
en 20 ans et appuyer dans le même sens
que ce que viennent de dire monsieur
Damas c'est qu'en fait il faut regarder
cette évolution de manière plus fine
parce qu'en réalité entre les deux
derniers recensements agricoles celui de
2010 et celui de 2020 le foncier
agricole n'a pas diminué en Guadeloupe
il est resté à peu près à l'identique à
quelques hectares prêts donc cette
diminution elle est le fait d'une
ancienne dynamique qui s'est poursuivie
jusqu'en 2010 mais on constate qu'il y a
un certain nombre d'outils qui ont été
mis en place ou de façon d'utiliser les
outils qui ont été mis en place dans la
décennie passée qui ont permis de
freiner ou de stopper
cette régression et cette évolution
négative hormis ces outils bon il y en
avait un qui était je vais en citer
trois il y en avait un qui était déjà en
place c'était les groupements fonciers
agricoles qui
issus de la réforme foncière et qui ont
permis de sanctuariser un certain nombre
d'hectares agricoles ça représente
presque un tiers de la superficielle
agricole utile de la Guadeloupe mais il
y a aussi la SAFER dont on a longuement
parlé le rôle le rôle de la SAFER dans
la régulation du marché du foncier du
foncier agricole et en fait l'outil de
la cdp9 la commission départementale
de protection des espaces agricoles et
naturels
je voudrais revenir deux minutes sur un
bilan d'activité de cette cdpna puisque
c'est l'objet aussi d'un point que vous
évoquez par la suite et on a un document
qui a été réalisé début 2023 donc début
de cette année et qui présente
l'ensemble de l'activité depuis le début
de la CDPA c'est des penaf ont été
installés vers
2015-2016 selon selon les départements
selon les lieux
depuis qu'elle a été mise en place la
cdp9 avec le principe de la vie conforme
elle est examinée 3000 des dossiers qui
portaient sur 3000 hectares de fonciers
agricole et sur ces 3000 hectares il y a
2000 hectares sur lesquels un avis
défavorable a été ému donc avis
défavorable ça veut dire en gros que
c'est des terres qui auraient dû quitter
le giron de du foncier agricole mais qui
sont restés et puis
donc 1000 hectares sur lequel il y a eu
un avis favorable vraisemblablement dans
la majorité des cas c'était des terres
agricoles avec un projet agricole à la
clé qui était soumis à la CD Penna donc
on voit déjà l'impact de cet outil là je
je rajoute une chose c'est que la cdp9
au cours de ces donc 10 dernières années
un peu moins examiner un certain nombre
de PLU de plan locaux d'urbanisme et que
sur cette même période tous les PLU qui
ont été adoptés après avis conformes de
la cdp9 on conduit à une augmentation de
près de 3000 hectares en zone agricole
par rapport à ce qui existe
préalablement dans les postes donc
globalement je pense que à la lumière de
ces chiffres là on peut voir que la cdp9
a été aussi un outil fort pour essayer
de préserver
l'activité l'activité agricole
si je pars si je prends maintenant le
cas de la SAFER mais je pense que le
Président Directeur Général s'exprimera
largement là-dessus mais en tant que
commissaire du Gouvernement auprès de la
SAFER l'État a aussi un petit mot à dire
là-dessus
on constate que la SAFER ici joue un
rôle alors ça a été aussi évoqué par
Monsieur Damas très important en matière
de régulation du foncier avec cette
capacité de droit de préhension qui qui
est limite les velléités de vendre des
petites parcelles de fonciers agricoles
et de vers vers l'urbanisme mais
effectivement le marché global du
foncier est très limité on est sur un
archipel sur une île donc le modèle
économique de fonctionnement d'une safer
régionale qui peut exister dans
l'Hexagone n'est pas du tout approprié
au contexte au contexte il y a au
contexte
archipelagique aussi guadeloupéen donc
là on va dans dans le sens de la
nécessité d'avoir des moyens des moyens
financiers complémentaires qui
permettent à assurer l'équilibre de cet
outil indispensable dans ces dans ces
îles
qui pourraient passer effectivement par
le biais d'une part de taxe affectées
qui reviendrait qui reviendrait à la
SAFER clairement uniquement en se
finançant sur les échanges fonciers
l'achat et la revente foncière
la SAFER vu le petit périmètre que l'on
a ici ne peut pas ne peut pas arriver en
équilibre et ça reste quand même un
établissement on a des une compétences
en matière d'expertise foncière et aussi
j'allais dire de dialogue de dialogue
fonciers qui est qui est précieux pour
pour un département comme comme celui
et sur les GFA le dernier outil par
rapport à la réforme foncière
l'enjeu là c'est de pouvoir assurer la
pérennité de ces outils donc de faire en
sorte que leur gestion soit soit bien
mené et qu'on ne risque pas d'aller vers
un démantèlement de cet outil qui me
paraît indispensable
ça c'était les points principaux sur
lesquels je souhaitais insister pour le
foncier après je voulais vous faire part
également du travail qui a été conduit
de la concertation qui a été conduite au
cours de du mois d'avril qui avait
commencé débuter en mars qui s'est
poursuivi en avril sur le projet de loi
d'orientation agricole qui nous a amené
à
réunir un certain nombre d'acteurs
de du territoire autour de des enjeux de
la transmission et de l'installation un
agriculture et vous faire part
simplement des des axes enfin mes
priorités qui étaient ressorties comme
un sujet à traiter qui avait un effet de
levier essentiel dans la remobilisation
du foncier pour l'installation des
jeunes comme l'a dit Monsieur Damas on
est face à un enjeu de
renouvellement de génération d'à peu
près 2000 dans les dans les 10 ans qui
viennent c'est énorme sachant qu'en
terme d'aide à l'installation des GIA on
installe que une vingtaine
d'agriculteur aidé mais dans la réalité
des faits on a constaté sur les 10
dernières années que c'est près de 1500
agriculteurs qui se sont installés en
Guadeloupe ce qui veut dire que la
majorité s'installe sans aucune aide
sans s'en dispositif d'aide
parce que souvent aussi ils sont plus
réactifs
d'où l'importance aussi d'avoir des des
outils d'accompagnement à l'installation
qui qui soit un peu plus
transgénérationnel que ce que on peut
avoir aujourd'hui pour pour faciliter et
pour maintenir cette dynamique et le
sujet qui est ressorti aussi c'est dans
cette consultation nous avons menée
c'est la question des retraites
agricoles donc qui est apparu comme un
vrai un vrai frein en réalité à la
libération du foncier avec la
possibilité de regarder s'il était
possible de majorer c'est c'est ces
retraites dès lors que il y avait par un
moyen ou un autre la possibilité de de
valoriser ce foncier le foncier agricole
et de le maintenir et de le maintenir
dans dans l'agriculture il y a eu
également
pas mal de choses qui qui sont remontées
sur les indivisions mais là je
m'attarderai pas c'était un petit peu la
discussion
qui a évoqué aussi monsieur Damas sur
celui de ne pas remonter peut-être à des
ascendants ou des descendants trop
lointaines dans dans le sujet dans la
loi les chimie pour pour faciliter un
peu le travail de reprise en main de ces
de ces terrains
donc il y a ce sujet là il y a ensuite
des sujets qui ont été évoqués sur la
structuration des filières agricoles et
qui rejoignent certaines de vos
questions notamment sur la structuration
de filière fruits et légumes
des difficultés principales qui est
apparue dans cette discussion c'est la
capacité par les organisations de
producteurs par les opé donc ou les
coopératives ou autres de d'assurer des
des versements réguliers ou des
financements dans des délais suffisants
aux agriculteurs apporteurs à ces
structures pour arriver à les fidéliser
et arriver à les mettre dans des
possibilités de de se projeter dans
l'avenir c'est difficulté que
connaissent pas mal d'organisations de
de producteurs dans le domaine des
fruits et légumes font que il y a une
tendance effectivement aller vers une
vente directe
qui permet de générer du cash du cash
immédiatement donc là il y a des
questions qui ont été évoquées de
comment pouvoir aider
les structures ces structures là à avoir
un fond de roulement
plus conséquent ou
qui leur permettent en quelque sorte de
prix financé un certain nombre d'aides
qui qui leur sont qui sont versés mais
qui sont versés toujours à avec un
certain délai puisque c'est après
constatation du service fait et
vérification du service fait donc il y a
ce sujet là de j'allais dire de la
trésorerie des opé qui qui permettraient
peut-être d'accueillir plus de jeunes si
ça fonctionnait un petit peu mieux et la
possibilité aussi de les accompagner
d'avoir des dispositifs d'aide et
d'accompagnement à la fusion à la
rapprochement de certaines opé pour pour
avoir des outils plus solides avec une
assise financière plus plus certaine
voilà en quelques mots les points
essentiels la question des banques a
aussi été évoquée l'histoire de le sujet
de pouvoir mettre en place des fonds de
garanties pour les gens qui s'installent
en agriculture en fin de les accompagner
dans le soit dans l'achat de foncier
soit dans la location de fonciers et
aussi dans dans l'investissement avec le
fait que beaucoup de participants à ces
réunions déplorés le rôle peut actif des
banques aujourd'hui sur le territoire
au moins de certaines banques sur le
territoire pour pour accompagner le
monde le monde agricole
voilà rapidement brosser les les points
les points essentiels et puis s'il y a
des questions
je pourrais y répondre très bien merci
beaucoup alors je crois que mon collègue
rapporteur tany Mohamed sali et a pu se
connecter il me semble qu'il avait une
question à poser mais je pense qu'il est
parti je repose la question par quel
conscience Damas
est-ce que Monsieur Damas est là et
reparti
monsieur Damas est reparti donc
peut-être
que tu est-ce que tu veux dire un mot
Tani
oui
bonjour madame la Présidente bonjour
chers collègues moi je me suis et
mesdames
oui j'avais des questions à poser au
monsieur
des jeunes représentants des jeunes
agriculteurs parce qu'il avait
émis un certain nombre de
préconisations intéressantes de façon
générale je vous remercie tous les
intervenants de la qualité des
interventions
et c'était pour
il avait parlé de renforcement de la loi
lithimie je voulais
savoir dans quel sens alors Monsieur le
Directeur tout de suite à parler de
peut-être la la nécessité de ne pas trop
remonter dans le temps dans le cadre des
auteurs mais je ne sais pas si
juridiquement ça sera possible c'était
pour savoir que voulait-il dire par
remboursement des dispositions de la loi
des chimie la deuxième question
c'était c'est de savoir est-ce que
l'indivision aujourd'hui la
problématique de l'indivision en
Guadeloupe est-elle qu'il faille ajouter
aux outils
actuels un outil spécifique comme c'est
demander par exemple à la Réunion comme
c'est le cas à Mayotte avec la
commission de l'urgence foncière ou
est-ce que un travail de coordination
avec les partenaires actuels et les
outils actuels suffirait à venir à bout
de la de la problématique de
l'indivision et dernière question c'est
sur les successions j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure une proposition très
intéressante
lorsque le monsieur avait parlé de la
transmission
de l'exploitation et où il parlait de
transmettre également le bâti et ma
question consistait à savoir si de
manière générale il n'y avait pas en
Guadeloupe comme on l'a vu dans d'autres
territoires la nécessité de davantage
valoriser
le fond agricole entre guillemets pour
que celui-ci au moment de la
transmission puisse avoir plus de valeur
que
que ça n'est il en est question
actuellement à l'image à l'image du du
fond de commerce et que par par cette
voix les transmissions de génération en
génération pourrait être plus fluide
pour reprendre un terme qui avait été
employé tout à l'heure donc voilà les
questions que j'avais à poser à ce stade
n'étant pas sûr que la connexion
persiste après cela
si ces questions pour pouvoir avoir de
réponse
avec les les personnes qui sont
présentes sinon
transmises par écrit au monsieur qui
avait émis tout à l'heure des
préconisations merci beaucoup
oui merci d'Annie bon ben monsieur
damazé nous a quitté là sur à l'écran
mais peut-être qu'une des personnes qui
va intervenir pourra t'apporter quelques
réponses donc je passe la parole à
Monsieur Patrick Sélène qui est le
président de l'établissement public
foncier accompagné de Corinne
vingatarama mais je il est également le
président de la Chambre d'Agriculture
donc il va parler sous une double
casquette donc je vous donne la parole
Monsieur Patrick sévère
à chaque question je vais un petit peu
vous dire ma vision donc durant ces
20 dernières années nous avons
effectivement constaté
c'est un recul du foncier agricole après
bon bien sûr la réforme foncière de 1980
a permis quand même de sanctualiser je
crois qu'on l'a dit
un certain nombre
d'hectares donc nous avons 38 DFA près
de 800 installés donc c'est la plus
grande opération foncière je crois qu'il
y a eu en Guadeloupe et loin de ce que
disait mon ami Damas 2000 personnes donc
installer l'espace de 10 ans puisque
c'est sur près de 25 ans que nous avons
installé toutes ces personnes là 800 je
crois grosso modo
donc voilà alors sur
l'installation donc les jeunes
agriculteurs bien sûr
nous aurons mieux souhaité que ces
jeunes escrocs puissent s'installer mais
ce qu'il faut dire aussi dire c'est que
ces 400 personnes ne vont pas pouvoir
tout cette installer tout de suite
puisque nous avons un départ tardif de
nos exploitants mais pour lesquels
guérison était évoquée notamment sur
la webcam puisque il y a rien qui a été
capitalisé pendant cette période sur des
surfaces de l'époque rappelez-vous de
Cadet depuis la réforme mensuel que nous
avons pu installer des gens sur environ
7 hectare 59 hectares donc ces personnes
là aujourd'hui je crois que je
commencerai par là ça veut dire on n'a
pas pu capitaliser à part quelques parts
sociales dans le cas des GFA mais ces
petites exploitations
donc n'ont pas non plus évolué pour
cause parce que en réalité je crois que
c'est de du corps de ferme qu'il faut
déballer il y a pas eu de corps de ferme
donc beaucoup beaucoup de de de perte
beaucoup de vols et beaucoup de produits
notamment Bienvenue à la ferme que nous
n'avons pas pu les installer de la
Réformation particulièrement n'ont pas
pu accéder à ses compléments de revenus
donc aujourd'hui je pense que il
faudrait aller vers une exploitation
type mais permettre aussi que ces
personnes puissent désormais les
nouvelles installations pour ceux qui
ont encore quelques temps et bien de
pouvoir être dans une situation
véritablement de chef d'entreprises
agricoles si on veut parler comme
j'entends beaucoup sur sur cette table
ronde parler
parce que je pense aussi à aucun moment
on a pensé qu'on était en Guadeloupe on
est dans un pays qui a manioc de penser
il y a une historique il y a un passé il
y a un mode de vie alors au départ sur
des grandes exploitations de 70 hectares
on est dans des circuits le plus souvent
et l'organisation des agriculteurs n'est
pas forcément n'est pas forcément les
filières dites organisées puisque eux
aussi ils sont organisés d'une certaine
manière mais ça veut pas dire que je
suis content la situation je fais je
fais je fais l'observation pour qu'on
puisse pas justement dire que je suis le
fossaïe de la situation aujourd'hui
qu'il faut tenir compte d'une réalité
qui est celle là donc nous avons des
petites exploitations qui ne peuvent
toujours pas émarger dans les grandes
coopératives sans pour autant dire que
nous croisons sur les groupes sur
l'organisation professionnelle il en
faut seulement
il faut permettre aussi à ceux qui ne
sont pas dans ces organisations et bien
de pouvoir aussi
bénéficier de des finances en tout cas
avoir accès aux aides de public comme
les autres ça il faut trouver peut-être
la forme de situation appropriée à nos
régions ça c'est sûr cette première
partie alors concernant la cdp9 alors
je suis d'accord que on a pu constater
un frein depuis un certain nombre
d'années moi-même je suis seulement
je suis d'accord pour le
hectare de terre agricole déclassé un
hectare de terre déclassé qui reviennent
c'est à dire la compensation mais il y a
un fait important et qui me gêne c'est
le
l'avis de confort
la vie conforme me semble-t-il
empêche
à ceux qui dirigent ce pays d'avoir
effectivement
une vision qui est la leur qui est de
celle de leur monde sur le développement
et même si on leur donnerait pas
même si ils auraient cet avis conforme à
leur place alors tout n'empêche nous
devrions être en capacité de pouvoir
continuer à à gérer
à orienter à donner des conseils à
partager cette gestion mais le fait que
nous tous saisissons des PLU des
communes et que nous
nous imposons quelque part sur la voie
de ceux qui ont été élu par le suffrage
universel me semble un petit peu
incroyable compte tenu que cela se passe
pas en métropole dans l'Hexagone
hexagone des objets et depuis tantôt ils
ont cette avis confort et ça je le vois
encore dans ce qu'on appelle hello à la
loi d'orientation agricole est en train
d'écrire seuls les Chambres
d'agriculture d'outre-mer n'ont pas la
plume tous les chambres de français de
Navarre
se comportement
m'indique qu'on infantilise encore
c'est pourquoi j'en parle nous sommes en
capacité de parler de souveraineté
alimentaire mais moi je pourrais parler
aussi de souvenirs intellectuel nous
sommes en capacité de pouvoir sur le
plan local et bien de d'aller dans les
mêmes sens les maires et les conseillers
les députés et bien nous avons une vague
qui effectivement sont des hommes
nouveaux
et puis sur le
[Musique]
concernant la SAFER
on peut pas dire que il ne fait rien
mais
je me je me garderai
de d'augmenter les pouvoirs de la SAFER
parce que je pense que nous allons vers
l'hégémonie de pouvoir de la SAFER si
nous prenons garde donc de faire
attention oui nous avons besoin d'une
affaire mais faisons attention quant à
la gestion et à la gouvernance de cette
affaire donc
sur les terres je crois que nous sommes
dans un pays un certain approche du
foncière agricole et il y a une certaine
approche du foncier tout court
permettre
encore une taxe supplémentaire sur les
sur les fiches
me semblent pas être convenable
je préférerais qu'on fasse d'autres
approches dans le cadre de la célébile
de travailler dans le sens de la
pédagogie de l'explication puisque nous
avons l'air que c'est facile mais
il faut qu'on fasse attention quand on
touche au foncier en Guadeloupe d'une
manière générale
ça me permettra de faire la transition
sur
sur la sur
la le PF je crois que
le travail que fait l'Obs est
complémentaire puisque aujourd'hui
je crois que nous faisons plus que la
défense de tes agricoles puisque nous
sommes dans une dynamique de rebâtir la
ville sur la ville toutes les
opportunités foncières que nous avons à
l'intérieur des villes aujourd'hui et
bien le PF est entré d'ailleurs tous les
OPCI sont membres chez nous et avec eux
nous travaillons sur tous ces avec lui
d'ailleurs oui je suis d'accord sur ce
plan là qu'on puisse un petit peu
l'aménage un petit peu plus mais bon
mais sur le plan c'est pas la même chose
et donc tous ces espaces vous allez voir
sur toutes les communes des démolition
et bien c'est que toute l'expertise qui
a été menée par par le PF aujourd'hui
nous venons de signer avec Cap
excellence sur vieux-bouabyme je crois
que
la défense de tes agricoles se fait
aussi Paola
permettent aux municipalités permettent
aux EPCI et de pouvoir travailler sur
ces espaces déjà
bâti avec des vieilles constructions des
wild que nous reprenons
et pouvoir mettre à la disposition des
bailleurs sociaux et bien c'est c'est
ces espaces et pour permettre à ces
communes de pouvoir s'étendre et
d'améliorer en tout cas les conditions
de vie de leurs commandes donc oui donc
je crois que le PF fait un travail
considérable qui va dans le sens du
développement du monde agricole tout en
étant pas directement concerné ben la
protection du foncier agricole
donc j'aurais j'aurais fait le tour
puisque beaucoup de choses ont été dit
est-ce que le McDo
c'est un problème oui dans le monde
entier aujourd'hui avec le réchauffement
climatique forcément nous y pornogades
la gestion de l'eau et les agriculteurs
ne sont pas les plus grands gaspilleurs
puisque nous sommes dans des systèmes
goutte-à-gouttes nous avons progressé
énormément dans la formation
que fait la Chambre d'Agriculture sur
l'utilisation de l'eau donc sur cet
aspect là je crois que nous sommes sur
le bon chemin et donc je finirai par
tout simplement que aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des structures qui sont en
place en Guadeloupe et bien permet
effectivement
une certaine
gestion de du foncier agricole mais
c'est qui qui n'est pas optimale puisque
je pense que il y a pas suffisamment de
conservation et
puis il faudrait que nous puissions
penser un petit peu
guadeloupéen pensez à notre territoire
ne pas la similaire d'autres territoires
parce que nous avons un fonctionnement
et nous avons une manière d'être une
manière de penser une manière de vivre
et qu'il faut je suis je suis pour la
sauvegarde dans la modernité pourtant de
de ce mode de vie et que nous assurons
en tout cas au niveau de la Chambre
d'Agriculture le la protection du Foncia
du col par ces outils là et voilà donc
je voudrais que retenir tout simplement
les deux aspects que je viens de citer
c'est que il faudrait permettre aux
agriculteurs de pouvoir
capitaliser à travers un corps de ferme
pour permettre un développement
harmonieux de leur exploitation puisque
quand vous habitez à cette 8 km de votre
exploitation je pense que vous n'avez
vous pouvez investir sur quoi que ce
soit puisque le vol fait légion dans
notre région et vous le savez très bien
qu'il y ait un frein manifeste au
développement je ne vais pas vous dire
merci
merci beaucoup monsieur
je flotte qui est accompagné de Tony
l'enclume
bonjour à tous bonjour madame la
signatrice merci de nous permettre de
nous estimer sur cette problématique qui
effectivement qui est quand même
déterminante pour notre territoire parce
que je rappelle que le Président de la
République a plus de ses vues
alimentaires c'est vrai que le poids du
passé foncier
de la Guadeloupe que c'est un
département qui comme vous savez la
propriété foncière et particulièrement
assimilé à ce qui se passe en métropole
avant de pouvoir m'estimer sur les
questions les différentes questions qui
ont été posées
je voulais d'abord
rappeler quand même la problématique
foncière en Guadeloupe et la vision que
nous avons alors c'est vrai que le
constat qu'on peut faire c'est qu'on
assiste quand même depuis quelques temps
à ce que j'appelle je qualifierais de
désordre fonciers alors pourquoi je
qualifie tout à l'heure le giga
beaucoup de personnes qui occupent des
espaces agricoles sans titre on a
beaucoup de
personnes légales on a beaucoup aussi en
Guadeloupe malheureusement de
construction sans permis on a un fort
situation de mitage de l'espace agricole
parfois créer des conflits d'usage on a
aussi une transmission qui
malheureusement pas à se faire pour
plusieurs raisons c'est que la pratique
des propriétaires fonciers agricoles en
Guadeloupe propriétaire foncier un
agriculteur qui souvent qui parle à la
retraite qu'est-ce qui se passe il se
passe il a fait caca il va diviser il va
morceler les cinq hectares en Afrique
enfant en un hectare et on va retrouver
à travers les notification grâce à faire
au sport pour les notaires on va
retrouver beaucoup de petits espaces
agricoles
je en moyenne elle était là qui sont
notifié à sa faire les extracteurs
tout au plus ça prouve que le marché
foncier sur le territoire comme un autre
et particulièrement complexe puisque on
parlait tout à l'heure d'installation de
l'État les jeunes vous comprenez bien
que cela s'affaire de 21 minutes
d'intervenir les préemption qu'elle
opère pas seulement ça a été dit tout à
l'heure par je crois que c'est Monsieur
les slogans pourcentages de tiret la
safero la communication on peut à peu
près à aller 90% sur l'exclanction avec
révision que le prix qui sont
actuellement élevés donc on constate une
population
du foncier à Guadeloupe et
malheureusement la loi permet la loi qui
permet au vendeur dans le bus on vient
de l'avant ça c'est une chose alors de
constats surface moyenne très basse donc
vous pensez bien que face à ce constat
on peut difficilement on peut voir une
agriculture qui a dit professionnelle en
clair
dans les années 80 de mise en place en
Guadeloupe en appui constaté on pourrait
dire que la culture européenne
Athènes en une disparition alors
maintenant on a dit tout ça il s'agit
pas pour nous de
constater s'agit aussi de proposer alors
proposer ça veut dire déjà il a dit
aussi le jeune borutamate il faut dire
que l'ensemble des acteurs
rural et nous sommes pas que fonciers se
mettre ensemble pour vraiment définir
quel avenir et quel policier agricole
pour vous mettre en place le départ de
moi parce que aujourd'hui le constat
qu'on fait à niveau de la SAFER c'est
que quand on n'est pas effectivement un
jeune bon essentiellement on espère
qu'il via les terrains
qui vont être égorgés
d'étude que le la situation économique
de ce jeune malheureusement 50 x 80
plaies on retrouve pas ce jeune n'arrive
pas à
répondre à aux attentes financières que
ce soit poussé par social de la saphir
pop pour que ce soit pour ces propres
besoins donc ça voulait dire à mon sens
que en matière de développement agricole
il est important comme une rapidement
une réflexion en profondeur pour
s'assurer que bon les actions qu'on va
mettre en place pour permettre que les
jeunes puissent avoir fait offensiers
puissent des actions positives dans le
temps
[Musique]
on doit maintenir la vie conforme et
même si après il faut bien peut-être
trouver quelques amendements en sachant
que je connais
que toutes les instances représentées je
pense que tout le monde est présent et
pour l'activité
et c'est l'instant de dialogue le
dialogue ou les décisions sont prises
par en vote unanime pour l'ensemble des
personnes présentes donc là dessus la
vie conforme si demain
comme on a pu échanger dans
la vie conforme devait être retiré par
cet instant
j'ai bien peur que
puisse aller vers les dérives j'ai bien
peur on verra ça va donner mais je pense
qu'il faut quand même que le monde
agricole s'est plumer à travers la TV là
c'est quand même capital pour pour le
devenir de notre territoire concernant
maintenant la situation de la taxation
des des terrains en fiche alors c'est
vrai que
je sais que en muscle en métropole c'est
une c'est une dispositif que qui avait
été envisagée alors sous nos préditoire
je suis pas sûr que si on taxé
je suis pas sûr que si on taxé les
terrains en fiche que ça aurait un effet
différent que celle-là que ça allait
maintenant je m'explique aujourd'hui
essentiellement les propriétaires
fonciers agricoles
ils tiennent à spéculer on le voit à
travers les modifications qu'on soit ça
fait on voit bien que
qui vaut aller 6000 hectares
et notifications parfois 30 000 euros
l'hectare on va dire que les gens ça
n'est pas une taxation à mon sens qui va
les freiner mais parce que la velléité
elle est là de spéculer et surtout la
vérité du fait que ce que je viens de
dire tout à l'heure où les gens ont
suivi sans permis et après il y a une
organisation qui est faite on constate
que les gens comment ils spéculer alors
je profite pour dire que on est en train
de mener une une étude pour savoir les
terrains qui ont été notifiés à sa faire
et oui effectivement on avait pu en
faire une zone pi euh en effet il faut
savoir c'est qu'il y en a qui sont
devenus alors on a constaté
un effet c'est que souvent les gens ils
ont tendance à louer à faire un bail et
a confié quand même qui a construit et
malheureusement je regardais sous deux
cas où ce sont des deux constructions
effectivement
ça je reviens sur le thème des ordres
fonciers en Guadeloupe
Océana maintenant
il est vrai que
c'est un effet quand même très positif
puisque on arrive quand même à réguler
le foncier on arrive à empêcher la
circulation on arrive à et maintenant on
a remarqué l'année dernière ou le prix
du foncé qui était à peu près de de
4000 au hectares on arrive maintenant à
des surfaces à des prix notifications ça
fait beaucoup moins les notaires 1 ils
ont compris que il fallait quand même
convaincre leurs clients de
revoir l'ABS le prix ramener au juste
prix ça fait constat qu'on a pu faire
concernant maintenant
alors concernant cette année est
important pour sonne la construction
sur les propriétés agricoles alors là je
serai un peu je vais respecter un peu la
doctrine que Fabrice c'est pas
qu'aujourd'hui une activité agricole qui
est justifiée et qui est
un projet agricole je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la doctrine c'est de
permettre à la culture qui a un projet
de construire maintenant
s'il faut permettre la construction et
les espaces agricoles à tout le monde
j'ai bien peur qu'on puisse contribuer à
développer encore plus le mitage nos
espaces agricoles la nature je crois que
la philippine 9 aujourd'hui l'action
qu'elle vienne c'est assez positif
monsieur le Médoc l'a dit tout à l'heure
on parle de surface
peut-être qu'il est nécessaire peut-être
plus de communication pour qu'on puisse
mieux entrevoir ce qui ce qui est fait
et pour revenir maintenant rebondir sur
la la
la mutualisation les interactions que
vous pouvez mettre en place les
différentes structures agricoles et
je pense que là on a initié on a initié
avec le
pH en a ici depuis tantôt depuis que la
lefc mise en place on a initié une
volonté de effectivement et je vois que
depuis F avant de notre sens de protéger
les espaces agricoles à travers ce
calcul présidentiel à travers
[Musique]
les espaces dans les cure de ville et
pour éviter qu'on est qu'on est connaît
du minage
il est vrai que on a eu l'occasion et là
je permets de saluer de fluidifier
madame puisque les l'occasion
dernièrement de permettre de préserver
les fatalités
dans un endroit ainsi au coeur du Parc
National d'ailleurs on a permis à une
collaboration entre le PF et là ça fait
de continuer sur l'espace vous voyez
comme quoi quand on travaille ensemble
on arrive à faire de bonnes choses mais
c'est vrai que je reconnais que
pas assez les acteurs du monde agricole
ne travaillent ensemble nous on a
toujours
prôné cette vérité de travail avec
l'ensemble des acteurs je rappelle que
ça fait à
dans son instant dirigeant le mon avis
les syndicats l'achat consulaires là-bas
les collectivités et ce n'est pas
d'échange et de décision où on est fait
avec un petit moyen c'est vrai puisque
on a dit tout à l'heure les saveurs
c'est l'espace le marché le marché du
foncier c'est quoi 700 modifications
chaque année c'est pas un marché qui
permet d'avoir une équipe financier pour
une affaire et l'ensemble des affaires
on a on a demandé à ce qu'on puisse
avoir un financement dédié soit à
travers
[Musique]
puisque je rappelle que les affaires en
outre et à métropole on fait quand même
un service public on permet de garantir
à l'état que il y a une activité
agricole qui va se pérenniser permet de
garantie aussi à l'état on va pouvoir
installer les jeunes même si en
Guadeloupe on n'arrive pas encore à
atteindre
par contre tout à l'heure on a fait
allusion aux aînés qui partent à la qui
parle pas il y a pas le foncier va pas
la retraite et on a fait allusion à ça
alors là nous là-dessus on a mis une
réflexion et je crois que je vais
prendre le cas de dgfa alors en GFA le
constat qu'on a fait c'est que bon
on peut imaginer on peut imaginer faire
une forme de tutorat c'est à dire
permettre aux aînés qui sont sur les
espaces des GFA installé accompagné de
jeunes à une jeune qui va amener pour
dynamique qui de l'activité une activité
économique mieux que celle qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui et qui va aussi permettre
que l'aîné puisse paraître quand il ment
à la retraite je crois que c'est une
voix qui fera alors on explore et
puisque le concert aujourd'hui c'est que
on a quand même malgré l'obligation
récompensée être et nous passions
d'envergure majeur qui représente
pratiquement un quart de la production
la Saül de la Guadeloupe c'est pas rien
et l'important qu'on puisse maintenir et
cette action qu'on a voulu faire les
années 80 et transformer cette action
encore de façon plus positive qu'elle
est aujourd'hui puisque effectivement il
y a des enjeux il y a des choses à faire
il faut contribuer au développement
agricole il faut contribuer à la
situation des jeunes qui sont demandés
aux offensiers il faut surtout
et accompagner effectivement nos aînés
qui doit partir à la retraite et ça
c'est possible c'est possible maintenant
il faut qu'on se mette ensemble
pouvoir mettre tous ses idées en place
voilà je reste à disposition pour
répondre
merci beaucoup monsieur donc je passe
maintenant à la parole à musclé la
directrice régionale pour l'ONF madame
je vous donne la parole
on ne vous entend pas Madame
non non on vous entend pas Madame
bon peut-être faudrait-il que vous vous
déconnectez que vous vous connectez en
attendant je vais donner la parole à
Madame Nathalie
minatchi pour l'association Cap
Guadeloupe
bonjour bonjour
merci de nous donner l'opportunité de
nous exprimer devant vous j'ai
normalement une projection
comment ça se passe c'est ce que je peux
partager l'écran ou est-ce que c'est
c'est dirigé depuis votre côté
super merci beaucoup
et je peux faire avancer moi-même
[Musique]
apparemment
dans ce cas là on peut avancer alors
alors afin de en attendant que ça se
déroule un très bien OK
très bien donc je souhaitais d'abord
présenter l'association Cap Guadeloupe
puisque bon nous avons un petit peu un
profil particulier dans cet assemblée
donc d'abord je tiens à dire que c'est
une association qui a été créée en 2008
donc il y a quand même quelques années
d'existence Alicia de syndicat agricole
lupg l'Union des producteurs agricoles
de la Guadeloupe et l'UPG en fait
souhaitait faire un contrat réaliser un
contrat entre société civile et
agriculteur de façon justement à
promouvoir son projet son projet
d'agriculture paysanne
projet justement qui était un peu trop
gardé au niveau de de la profession des
agriculteurs et l'importance pour eux
c'était effectivement de faire connaître
ce projet à la société civile de façon à
avoir un soutien de cette société civile
donc c'est ce qui explique notre
création et nous nous sommes donné comme
objectif donc la souveraineté
alimentaire de la Guadeloupe en militant
pour la préservation du foncier agricole
d'une part mais également pour une agric
ulture respectueuse de l'environnement
et des sécurités sanitaires énergétiques
et climatique
je tiens aussi à ce que nous clarifions
un petit peu ce concept de rester
concept au niveau aussi bien de
l'agriculture paysanne que la
souveraineté alimentaire quand on parle
d'agriculture paysanne on parle d'une
agriculture qui est dont l'objectif
premier de nourrir la population et non
de faire de la spéculation sur des
produits agricoles voire encore plus des
produits agricoles d'exportation tout en
préservant la santé de l'humain et la
santé de l'environnement c'est une
agriculture donc paysanne qui repose
donc sur l'agroécologie et quand on
parle de souveraineté alimentaire là
aussi c'est un concept qu'il faut
définir puisque c'est un mot qui est
utilisé maintenant un peu à toutes les
sauces on va dire un peu à la mode et on
oublie qu'en fait que ce concept de
souveraineté alimentaire est d'abord un
concept politique qui est lié donc au
modalités d'organisation du système
alimentaire donc c'est ce concept
politique c'est le droit des peuples en
fait définit le droit des peuples à une
alimentation saine et culturellement
appropriée produite avec des méthodes
durables
c'est effectivement le droit des
populations de définir une politique
agricole et alimentaire sans dumping
vis-à-vis des pays tiers et ça a été
défini en fait par le mouvement paysan
el campestino dans les années fin des
années 90
et là où il faut que nous insistions
c'est que c'est une souveraineté
alimentaire n'est pas sécuritaire comme
je l'ai dit la souveraineté alimentaire
c'est un concept qui repose sur des
aspects quantitatifs et qualitatifs qui
prend en compte une dimension culturelle
et ticket sociale avec une agriculture
qui respecte l'environnement et
rejettent donc l'agriculture intensive
alors que bien souvent ce concept est
confondu avec le concept de sécurité
alimentaire où là on retrouve comme les
notions d'accès à une nourriture à la
scène aussi bien sur le plan qualitatif
et quantitatif mais par contre l'origine
et les modalités de production des
aliments ne sont pas évoqués et souvent
la sécurité alimentaire des petits États
insulaires de la Caraïbe que dont nous
font pas nous faisons partie
repose donc sur le commerce
international et l'importation donc on
peut être en sécurité alimentaire et
avoir aucune production agricole dans
son pays donc l'action que nous menons
repose sur la souv eraineté alimentaire
et l'agroécologie pour construire des
systèmes alimentaires performant et
durables
alors quelques exemples de nos actions
militantes nous avons effectivement
mener des actions pour préserver les
terres agricoles pour fournir du foncé
aux agriculteurs et je dois donner
effectivement deux exemples nous sommes
mobilisés en 2018 contre l'implantation
de golf de montagne sur 105 hectares
donc 19 hectares de terrain agricole à
Petit-Bourg nous avons réussi
effectivement à faire reculer ce projet
et là nous nous sommes mobilisés l'an
dernier quand on l'implantation d'un
ball-trap dans les hauteurs de
capesterre-bello et là ce projet-là
malheureusement il est nous avons pas
très bien sur que ça va donner mais pour
se battre il y a quand même 8 hectares
de terres agricoles qui seront sacrifiés
si ce projet voit le jour
deuxième axe nous avons d'autres axes
d'action mais il nous paraissait
important de vous présenter cela c'est
de soutenir effectivement des projets
innovants qui permettent la transition
agroécologique de notre agriculture la
résilience climatique et la
séquestration de carbone puisqu'il faut
effectivement que l'agriculture que nous
allons mener et qui est en mutation
permettent d'avancer sur ces axes là et
donc nous participons au comité de
pilotage de projets qui sont menés par
des organismes de recherche notamment le
projet on peut citer quelques projets
valables pour les le développement
d'élevage en sous-bois naturelle en
Guadeloupe je crois que Maurice Damas en
a parlé effectivement dans son
intervention un autre projet
scientifique territoire durable qui
parle de la gestion de l'enermement et
de l'élevage sur des terres chlordé
parce que le devenir de ces terres
déconné est également important
on a un autre projet par exemple caribio
créole qui parle des itinéraires
techniques pour la sauvegarde et la
valorisation des races créoles qui sont
effectivement plus résiliantes donc ce
sont des projets
scientifiques sur lesquels effectivement
nous tâchons de participer d'amener un
peu notre vision
alors je voulais effectivement à ce
stade vous expliquer le le périmètre
d'un autre intervention notre action
milite pour que la vision d'ensemble sur
la préservation du foncière agricole
soit une vision partagée collectivement
j'ai entendu plusieurs intervenants
parler de la nécessité que nous
réfléchissions ensemble donc c'est vrai
que la vision doit être partagée
collectivement sur des concepts
clairement définis et que les critères
d'affectation des terres agricoles
soient claires et répondent à des
besoins collectifs et non pas des
besoins individuels et privés alors nous
ne sommes pas experts de question
juridique et foncière donc effectivement
une fois que cette vision est claire et
partagée mais les experts des questions
juridiques à vous dire devront
effectivement préparer ces mesures
alors sur la question du foncier
agricole en Guadeloupe nous avons quand
même quelques caractéristiques que nous
souhaitons mettre en avant nous avons
une trop effort de contraintes foncière
sur le territoire qui s'est pourtant
donné comme priorité donc la
souveraineté alimentaire mais il faut
effectivement savoir ce qu'est la
souveraineté alimentaire nous avons un
espace restreint par rapport à la
population avec une grande diversité de
milieu nous avons un espace insulaire
très vulnérable face au changement
globaux on parle aussi bien de choc
climatique et économique
environnementaux épidémie etc et une
surface agricole de 50 000 hectares de
terre je l'ai dans le schéma
d'aménagement régional donc là le ça
mais sur lequel nous tenons à être quand
même enfin nous tenons quand même amener
une une petite réserve nous avons
entendu dire effectivement que le
la super fellation au niveau des terres
agricoles n'a pas diminué depuis les 10
dernières années le problème c'est qu'il
y a également parfois des opérations de
compensation qui se font lors de
l'élaboration des plus et qui classe des
terrains en terres agricoles des
terrains qui ne sont pas exploitables et
qui ne sont pas capables de donner des
exploitations fiables donc cet élément
là aussi il y a un point d'attention à
mettre là dessus donc les stratégies qui
sont mises en place deux fois plutôt
confluer à plus de résilience du
territoire et c'est donc pour cela que
nous travaillons
alors pour terminer ce propos un peu
limé alors vous avez compris que nous
allons nous avons essayé de répondre à
certaines questions mais ne nous revient
pas de répondre aux questions qui nous
ont été posées donc nous avons quand
même faire gérer un peu plus vite sur la
fin par rapport aux questions mais il
nous emblème important de vous donner
quand même quelques éléments de
prospective et qui font partie des
travaux qui ont été réalisés par
certains de nos membres donc sur une
surface agricole de 50 000 hectares
nous avons une population de la
Guadeloupe nous avons considéré à 380
000 habitants et nous avons
effectivement pris des
des chiffres de du Mémento 2020 de la
Grèce donc la surface agricole je l'ai
dans le sérieux de 50.000 hectares la
surface agricole utile 34000 hectares
les surfaces en cas de bananes qui sont
des cultures d'exportation donc ne
rentrent pas dans le cadre d'une
agriculture qui permet de nourrir la
population donc c'est 15000 hectares on
pourrait rajouter le melon également
assez à ces éléments là et donc les
surfaces en production vivrière que nous
avons considérées sont de 12 300
hectares à peu près
quand on regarde cela et qu'on considère
effectivement avec des références que
nous avons trouvé dans la littérature
que les systèmes agricoles les plus
performants permettent de nourrir cinq
personnes par hectare nous avons défini
un seuil de couverture des besoins de
0,2 hectares par personne et quand on
rapporte cela
à la population de la Guadeloupe et
qu'on regarde les surfaces prévues aussi
bien dans le sar que la surface agricole
utile ou que la surface consacrée aux
productions vivrières mais on voit qu'on
est très loin de ce seuil pour des
surfaces agricoles en particulier pour
la surface consacrée aux cultures
vivrières donc je tiens à simplement
dire qu'il s'agit de prospective dont
nous avons fait un certain nombre
d'hypothèses ce ne sont pas des chiffres
à prendre à la lettre mais c'est
simplement des chiffres qui donnent une
tendance et la tendance on voit bien que
c'est en dessous de ces de ces 50 000
hectares on est on est bien loin en tout
cas de d'assurer une un seuil de
couverture des besoins alimentaires
et la deuxième
le deuxième élément que nous souhaitions
importer c'est effectivement l'effet du
régime alimentaire sur les besoins d'un
fonction agricole nous avons considéré
en effet un certain nombre de d'éléments
d'hypothèses et notamment nous avons
considéré quatre choix de régime les
régimes végétaliens végétariens
omnivore poissons et omnivores et bien
en fonction de ces régimes là et sur la
base de 2600 kcal par jour et par
personne nous avons défini un besoin en
terrain agricole et quand on ramène ça
effectivement à nouveau à la population
de la Guadeloupe mais en voie que
seuls les régimes végétariens
végétaliens en tout cas et omnivore au
poisson permettent effectivement de
nourrir la population avec une base de
50 000 hectares de fonctions agricoles
quand on est à notre régime omnivore
viande que nous avons qui qui pourront
aujourd'hui nous voyons que la surface
des 50 000 hectares ne suffit pas voilà
je vais vous couper là je vais bon voilà
faites-nous un petit point de conclusion
compte tenu que nous avons votre
document tout écrit
ensuite je dois redonner quand même la
parole à Madame Mylène Musquet et compte
tenu que nous devons
rendre la salle pour 16h
on sera dans l'obligation de voilà donc
je vous redonne pour la petite
conclusion et ensuite je donne la parole
à Madame musquée si vous le voulez bien
je suis sur ma diapositive de conclusion
donc ce qui nous paraît important de
dire c'est qu'il faut conserver donc
c'est sanctuariser ces 50000 hectares de
fonciers agricole il faut avoir une
transparence sur la gestion du foncier
agricole et donc avoir une grille
d'évaluation des projets pour
l'attribution des terres agricoles avec
des critères claires et que l'intérêt
collectif doit primer sur l'intérêt
individuel il faut mener des actions de
sensibilisation de la population sur la
nécessité du changement de modèle
alimentaire même si ça doit se faire
progressivement pour aller effectivement
vers plus de cohérence avec l'objectif
de souveraineté alimentaire valoriser
des travaux de recherche et intégrer
donc la réflexion menée au niveau de la
Caraïbe sur la résilience climatique
alors juste je vous souhaite très
rajouter un point puisque j'ai été
interpelé par cela dans les propos de
Monsieur mornal sur justement ce
problème de
besoin en eau mais on voit très bien que
la question effectivement d'installation
de l'exploitation agricole de melon dans
le Nord grand-père en bout de réseau et
que le melon c'est pas une culture
effectivement de qui culture vivrière
c'est ce genre de projet de
développement doit être doit être étudié
avec avec ces éléments là voilà
merci beaucoup madame
désolé de vous faire un peu activé mais
on est contraint par le temps donc je
redonne la parole à Madame Mylène
musquée pour l'ONF si elle est arrivée à
se reconnecter
à la musquée c'est à vous
oui est-ce que vous m'entendez oui on
vous entend très bien
et j'ai dû descendre en étage au
rejoindre le collègue de la DAF parce
que ça ne passait vraiment pas donné à
ce niveau mais bon j'espère que je serai
audible oui oui vous êtes tout à fait au
19 si je
si je suis la trame des questionnaires
c'est vrai que nous sommes plutôt
j'ai abordé ce questionnaire plutôt en
faisant un lien entre le foncier
agricole et le foncier forestier et
contrairement à propos de Monsieur Damas
je mettrai
mais plutôt une complémentarité une
complémentarité
qui est naturel donc juste pour rappeler
le
Guadeloupéen c'est un objet
qui représente 50% de l'espace boisé je
tiens quand même à rappeler que les 50
autres pour cent
forêt privé sur lesquelles bien sûr le
forestier s'applique mais où il y a
des perspectives d'évolution de Valo
sont évidentes et pas forcément mises en
œuvre pour rappeler aussi que sur ces
37000 hectares vous
qui en cure de parc donc avec une
protection forte qui correspond à la
forêt primaire
environnemental en termes de
biodiversité l'ONF et gestionnaire
on n'est pas gestionnaire d'un forêt
d'un foncier
nous avons quand même des relations
privilégiées avec ces acteurs
économiques
depuis tantôt il a été fait un choix
d'un rapprochement entre le foncier
forestier et les besoins
des acteurs économiques que sont les
agriculteurs à partir du moment ces
activités agricoles
avec le code forestier et à travers un
cahier des charges que nous construisons
ensemble avec ces opérateurs c'est pour
cette raison que nous avons aujourd'hui
plus d'une soixantaine de conventions
d'occupation temporaire
les activités dites de culture
traditionnelle de Cultura
à travers lesquels on retrouve des
producteurs de vins cacao et depuis deux
ans maintenant nous avons augmenté la
liste des espèces
concernées par la culture sous couvert
forestière la culture associée donc il y
a une vraie démarche
d'accompagnement et de proximité
je pense que nous sommes conscients
effectivement en tant qu'acteur de qui
intervenant sur l'aménagement
conscient qu'il y a un rapprochement qui
doit se faire
concernant un territoire justement l'ONF
est également partenaire avec les autres
services du concentré de l'État
lorsqu'il s'agit de donner des avis sur
que ça soit sur le PLU le ça et à ce
titre
avant élaboré pour le compte de la du
conseil régional le schéma régional du
patrimoine naturelle
cette réflexion sur la complémentarité
et
agricole et l'offensiforestique est
apparu que ça soit en termes de
corridorécologie
qui correspondent véritablement assez
ces zones tampons entre les activités
économiques et les activités forestières
et qui joue un rôle écologique certes
mais aussi tout ce qui est maintien de
ebrison
et qui joue véritablement un rôle et
évident un rôle essentiel que je ne vais
pas rappeler que vous connaissez
sur le thème terrorisme
lorsqu'on recherche sur un petit
territoire insulaire comme le des
options d'augmenter ou en tout cas de
stabiliser le foncier agricole il faut
aller chercher là où on a du potentiel
sur cette terre
au-delà de la Valerie agronomique que je
ne peux
que je ne peux mesurer qui n'est pas de
ma compétence
il y a que qui a très peu été abordé
qu'il faut qu'il faut prendre en
considération sur ces terres en fiche
impactés par le l'accordéon et à ce
titre là effectivement nous avons eu
l'occasion à plusieurs reprises de faire
des propositions d'accompagnement de
croisement de ces terres impactés par
par la peur d'école à travers ce qu'on
appelle des programmes de reboisement
utiles
justement avec notre démarche
d'agroforesterie ou de culture associée
de culture en sous-bois
il faut quand même souligner que sur
certaines de ses pensées il y a de
vraies problématiques de
l'accessibilité
les liens avec la
principalement lorsqu'il s'agit de
mettre en oeuvre des désopérations de
compensation compensation
environnementale lorsqu'il y a des
pics de celles qui ont été
qui ont été mis en gestion par via la
SAFER par les agriculteurs une petite
vigilance pendant certaines parcelles
au grand puisqu'il y a quand même une
forte pression sur la forêt sèche de
cette zone là et il convient de rappeler
que très souvent nous une
un déséquilibre entre les certaines
pratiques agricoles certaines pratiques
de culture
qui sont très consommatrices d'eau sur
un terrain sur un espace de Forest sèche
un terrain et un espace qui qui n'est
pas forcément pour selon nous adapter à
certaines de ces pratiques certes il y a
des barrages il y a des dégâts des des
hommes mais on se rend bien compte
effectivement il faut peut-être comme
Madame Minati le disait repenser
autrement notre notre monde
relation agricole en tenant compte de
tous ces paramètres et de tous ces
critères
viennent s'ajouter effectivement tout ce
qui est changement changement climatique
et on doit très certainement donc nous
faut restiez on construit en perçoit
déjà des évolutions sur les milieux
naturels il y aura de toute manière un
impact sur l'activité agricole qui est
qui qui est tout à fait perceptible d'où
des choix qui
à faire sur la localisation de certaines
cultures du fait de
ressources en eau même si elle peut en
théorie être transposée d'une île à
l'autre ça se fera sûrement de manière
moins évidente lorsque la ressource et
c'est déjà le cas
moins présente et et moins
moins facile à transposer c'est des P9
nous participons effectivement à cette
commission à côté de la DAF nous la
possibilité de donner des avis ou en
tout cas d'accompagner les avis de la
DAF que ça soit sur le la validation des
PLU ou autre outil de
gestion du territoire pour moi la vie
confort a du sens il est essentiel en
termes de contrôle en terme de pression
en termes de verrou la composition de la
cdp9 permet de libérer la parole et de
peindre dans les
et d'échanger en toute transparence et
en toute trouvée en tuyau mais enlever
cet avis conforme à la cdp9
selon moi on perdrait un petit peu le
sens de cette de cette structure
composition qui permet de de faire un
peu de trouver un peu un équilibre sur
toutes ces problématiques de
d'évolution de du foncier agricole sur
la ressource en eau je reviendrai pas
sur les
plan de la ressource en quantité et en
qualité simplement souligner quand même
puisque c'est aussi d'une des
avant que pour inventaire sur les
rivières on constate encore quelques
captages sauvages qui sont liés aux
activités agricoles donc il y a nous on
l'interprète ainsi en tout cas il y a un
véritablement un vrai besoin en terme
d'irrigation malgré les différents
programmes qui sont en cours malgré les
efforts
[Musique]
les grosses pinces et agricoles
en ressources en eau si l'agriculteur a
encore recours à ce type de pratique
c'est que comment des manquements
périmètre de protection des zones
agricoles oui des zones de captage aussi
programme de reboisement autour des
démarrages ça me paraît évident
également pour mieux gérer cette
ressource en eau qui deviendra en
quantité et en qualité
rapprochement avec le PF ça n'est pas
encore formalisé c'est vrai que le
questionnaire que vous avez envoyé m'a
été appelé on a bien sûr quelques
échanges avec les directions
c'est notre en tant que gestion
qui font de la mise à disposition etc
mais pourquoi pas ça donnera de
effectivement de la cohérence à
la gestion d'un foncier global
sur notre petite territoire
par ailleurs ce rapprochement aussi peut
se faire de manière un petit peu plus
ponctuelle sur des programmes
symboliques comme les proboisement des
projets de plantation avec des listes
des espèces et de naissance qui seraient
peut-être plus spécifique ou de
l'expertise que l'on pourrait mettre
lors de travaux de revégétalisation
je finirai en insistant sur deux points
l'oppositionnement de l'ONF vis-à-vis de
l'activité agricole un exemple la
convention que nous avons passé avec la
Sica LPG la Sica banane
séance sur un terrain difficile on a
commencé pas forcément sur l'espace le
plus simple puisqu'il s'agit de la zone
de Sarcelles une zone avec un conflit
foncier historique puisqu'il s'agissait
à la base d'une forêt primaire qui a été
déboisé de manière sauvage
occupé non pas par une majorité
d'agriculteurs professionnels déclaré
mais par des voilà des des
occupants qui avaient besoin de deux
fonciers pour une pour avoir des
pratiques de jardin créole une ou
apprise en main progressive un terrain
sensible effectivement mais pour
rassurer monsieur Damas qui m'a
malheureusement n'est plus là et lui
dire que c'est quand même grâce à cette
structure organisation
les professionnels que nous avons
progressivement
apaiser les relations avec les occupants
historiques et les jeunes agriculteurs
qui sont une dizaine et aujourd'hui ils
en sont à leur deuxième récolte et que
c'est je pense que c'est une des
solutions qui pouvaient nous permettre
de sortir de ce conflit historique ou
effectivement on avait l'impression
qu'il y avait une une bataille entre
Foncia agricole et fonciers forestier
quand les choses sont poncées sans
penser ensemble en cohérence on arrive à
mettre en place des opérations qui sont
exemplaires puisque c'est jeunes ont été
formés ces jeunes ont démarré par une
activité banale exclusive et s'orient
progressivement vers ce qu'on appelle de
la culture associée de la de
l'agroforesterie avec l'appui et
l'accompagnement de de la Sica donc
extrémise écologique je ne pense pas que
l'ONF en face
ne serait-ce qu'à travers notre démarche
d'agroforesterie ou de Cultura associés
le terme est peut-être plus approprié
dans le cas un rapprochement qui est
volontaire qui doit sûrement perfectible
mais qui nécessite d'avoir une analyse
effectivement partagée
voilà juste pour terminer effectivement
sur
la nécessité contenue de notre
configuration exécuter du territoire sur
une optimisation de toutes les
stratégies et de toutes les politiques
de gestion du foncier de manière globale
et de mise en cohérence le changement
climatique nous oblige à avoir de
l'anticipation
le foncier forestier est déjà impacté le
foncier agricole va l'être ou s'il est
déjà pas donc si on ne réfléchit pas
ensemble sur une un équilibre une
préservation on aura quelque part raté
des dessins ou des PLU en théorie qui
qui aborde ce sujet là dans la pratique
on voit bien qu'il y aura un décalage
voilà ce que je souhaitais faire passer
comme message merci beaucoup madame je
voudrais avant de passer la parole à
notre collègue la sénatrice Madame
Victoire gezmin qui conclura cette table
ronde je voudrais vous remercier toutes
et tous pour les toutes les informations
que vous avez communiqué vous dire que
nous sommes preneurs de toutes vos
contributions écrites si vous avez des
choses que vous auriez oublié de nous
dire ou que vous souhaiteriez
approfondir bien évidemment nous sommes
preneurs de tous vos informations je
vous donne je vous dis un grand merci à
toutes et tous et je vous donne la
parole pour conclure à Victoire jasmin
qui je crois avec quelques petites
questions à vous poser victoire je te
passe la parole oui merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente merci beaucoup à
tous les intervenants c'était très
intéressant et je vous remercie d'autant
plus pour le temps que vous nous avez
consacré mais je crois qu'il était
important que nous puissions échanger
sur les différentes problématiques qui
se posent en Guadeloupe et de façon
positive vraiment et donc façon
complémentaire également et bien nous
allons pouvoir trouver des
recommandations donc je vous remercie
vraiment tous et toutes alors je vais
j'aurais quelques questions et même si
vous n'avez pas la possibilité de
contraint de répondre directement les
autres mais vous avez la possibilité
évidemment d'envoyer par écrit les
réponses alors concernant le financement
de la CEDAC c'est DAF pardon le
président moral a évoqué les difficultés
alors je voudrais lui demander quels
sont les pistes d'amélioration s'il y en
a qu'on pourrait évidemment mettre en
évidence les réponses voir la
possibilité également parmi les
recommandations d'Anthony au compte les
problèmes d'eau alors la possibilité
également de réhabiliter les marques
est-ce que pour les petites
exploitations parce qu'il y a
effectivement des exploitations pour
lesquelles ce serait important de
réhabiliter l'immat
c'était le cas il y a quelques temps
malheureusement malheureusement on a
beaucoup abandonné certainement il y a
une volonté de la part d'association de
réhabiliter des marques donc est-ce que
ça pourrait aussi contribuer ne se
serait pas la solution mais ça pourrait
être contribué énormément
à l'amélioration de la qualité de prise
en compte exploitation concernant la loi
climat et résilience un des objectifs
c'est aussi la situation de
l'artificialisation des sols donc zéro
anticipation nette alors je voudrais
savoir comment est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec les différentes
problématiques qui ont déjà été évoqués
par le passé enfin bon c'est récent mais
il y a maintenant de plus en plus une
volonté de diminuer l'extension urbaine
alors est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
est-ce que vous avez des
préconisations à faire et j'ai entendu
un intervenants parlé justement de la
possibilité alors je crois que c'est
Monsieur silain mais c'est assez
complémentaire entre là ça fait et la
Chambre d'Agriculture je crois que qu'il
a donné un exemple
un exemple de coopération de
complémentarité qui a été réussie c'est
madame je crois la présidente en tout
cas qui a également évoqué
cette possibilité donc est-ce que vous
pensez qu'un travail justement ensemble
vous allez pouvoir aider les communes à
mieux travailler pour éviter l'extension
urbaine et tenir compte de cet objectif
qui est il me semble important
concernant une retraite agricole c'est
vrai que c'est un vrai sujet et c'est
parce que les agriculteurs ont des
grandes difficultés
à travailler alors est-ce qu'il serait
possible que la Chambre d'Agriculture
que les techniciens et toutes les
personnes ressources d'ailleurs puissent
travailler et avec anticipation de cette
anticipation parce qu'il y a des données
de la NSA qui permettent d'avoir l'âge
des agriculteurs savoir un petit peu
quelle est leur situation donc anticiper
parce que récemment sur le texte des
retraites qui ont été adopté il n'y a
pas bien longtemps on a évoqué également
la situation des agriculteurs et nous
avons constaté que pour notre territoire
et pour le territoire ultra en tout cas
il y avait des difficultés de non
recours au droit donc est-ce qu'on peut
pas accompagner davantage c'est-à-dire
qu'ils aient un recours et puis sur leur
droit avec la prise en compte du minimum
contributifs y compris pour leur
compagne ou leur épouse en tout cas
parce qu'il y a de vrais sujets donc ça
pourrait peut-être contribuer on a les
accompagner en anticipant leur départ
quand il serait pris en compte et bien
de mieux permettre qu'ils aient des
retraites complémentaires et des revenus
décents pour libérer leurs foncier donc
la question du risque naturel d'être
encore évoqué par Madame par Madame
musquée mais ça a été le cas pour
d'autres intervenants donc la question
des assurances parce que on se rend
compte que beaucoup d'agriculture ont
envie d'assurer et que les assureurs ne
prennent pas le risque important alors
que très souvent lorsqu'il y a des
risques naturels et bien il y a des
problèmes de calamité et il y a des
agriculteurs qui peuvent pratiquement
tout en fonction que quand on se parle
il y a des inondations tantôt les
ouragans en fait il y a une multitude de
difficultés qui s'ajoute donc est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas anticiper également
pour éviter le découragement des
agriculteurs qui peuvent très souvent
leurs produits et je dirais également
les moyens de la faire alors pour avoir
un travail parce qu'il y a des réunions
avec la SNCF à Paris mais avec Monsieur
tresse également et ça a été une des
personnes qui est ma sensibilisée sur
les problématiques du fonciers agricoles
et je tiens à le dire j'ai eu l'occasion
également avec Monsieur Sylla concernant
les retraites mais je dis qu'il y a
un vrai travail à faire pour permettre à
la faire et aussi à faire d'outre-mer
pas que la Guadeloupe mais je profite
pour les yeux pour la Guadeloupe que les
affaires et les moyens parce que ce sont
les petites superficie ils n'ont pas les
mêmes moyens et on leur demande les
mêmes règles et les normes sont les
mêmes en fait on leur demande la même
qualité de travail alors que ce sont des
petites superficie et quand on regarde
au niveau de l'Hexagone il y a des
effectivement des exploitations qui sont
très très importantes en termes de
superficie alors que sur notre
territoire on l'a dit c'est un archipel
déjà on a des îles avec les îles du Sud
mais qui ne sont pas toutes bien dotés
on peut encore faire quelque chose il y
a du foncier mais il y a de vraies
difficultés pour le fonctionnement de la
SAFER et je crois qu'il faudrait qu'on
trouve dans les différentes mesures que
nous devrions prendre les moyens de
permettre à la ça fait de travailler de
façon beaucoup plus pertinente et
efficiente
je crois que dans la toute première
position que nous avons réalisé et bien
il y avait la SNCF et un certain nombre
de formations qui nous avait donné donc
je crois qu'il faut vraiment prendre en
compte tout cela mais l'intérêt de
travailler tous ensemble avec certaines
pistes qui ont été évoquées par madame
minachi je crois que c'est important et
ce sont des opportunités que nous
n'aurons pas toujours mais c'est la
aujourd'hui nous avons la chance de
pouvoir travailler sur cette
problématique qui va nous donner des
perspectives pour l'avenir d'autant plus
qu'avec la pandémie nous avons vu les
limites de l'exercice chez nous mais
nous avons également vu qu'il y a eu un
tiret pour les foncier pour
l'agriculture et pour la souveraineté
alimentaire donc voilà madame la
Présidente voilà Mesdames Messieurs ce
que j'avais à dire à cet instant et je
remercie vraiment
l'ensemble des intervenants et tous ceux
qui ont travaillé en tout cas pour que
nous ayons une telle qualité
d'intervention je vous remercie merci
beaucoup